bang bang
what's up lunch money time oh wall
street's trying to get rich
see that while wall street's trying to
get rich the rest of us just trying to
get our lunch money right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
polina evilova marinova pompliano
aka pimp she looks like she is about to
take some molly and go to like a rave or
something
what are you wearing i'm trying to get
the views up so people click on the
little thumbnail because i'm colorful
colorful is one thing that'll be one
description it's all right i'm back i
got the yankee hat yankees 1-0 going
after the 28th world championship i'll
see you guys
oh it should be october but we'll see
when the actual season ends championship
season
don't forget lunch money is now brought
to you by block five block buy has three
products you can buy and sell crypto you
can deposit crypto and
get a us dollar loan or my favorite
product as an investor
and a user is that you can deposit
bitcoin
or a stable coin you can earn up to 8.6
apy
absolute no-brainer there's risk go do
your research but
use blockfy.com lunch money and you get
special treats
get i can't deal with this shirt can you
tell the people that
i didn't sleep this morning she did not
sleep this morning because i
woke her ass up at 8 30 and said get out
of bed
i got coffee for you and we got things
to do today trying to bribe me with all
sorts of things but
here we are all right what's going on
with 1mdb
okay so u.s investment bank goldman
sachs
on friday reached a 3.9 billion dollar
settlement with malaysia
over the multi-billion dollar 1mdb
scandal that will see
all criminal charges against the bank
dropped that is insane first of all tell
us what 1mdb is well first of all it's
not on fridays today today is friday
that's fine
uh 1mdb basically is a fund
uh it had a couple of bonds that the
malaysian government
uh participated in and other investors
there's about 6.5 billion dollars total
raised
uh goldman sachs was the bankers on the
deal there's a gentleman
joe lowe a gentleman uh who is still on
the loose
but out of the 6.5 billion dollars 4.5
of it was
misappropriated aka stolen and
it was used to fund his lifestyle so for
people that don't know 4.5 billion
dollars was used to do all kinds of
things
including uh by the wolf of wall street
the movie
what yes that's true it did fund the
wolf of wall street it also
uh funded daddy's home there was a uh
thing called uh red granite studios i
think and basically it was
the son of the malaysian leader uh
was running a film studio and jolo kept
feeding him money
um and so that was all stolen then there
was a 250 million dollar yacht court of
ability
uh yacht just hanging out in bali
there's a 35 million dollar private jet
there was a dozen properties or homes
across london new york california
there was a glass piano that was sitting
in miranda kerr's house that they
couldn't get out of her house
so all kinds of crazy stuff going to say
something that's kind of like
you know uh touchy
so i thought that joe jolo like he's
dating these super models he's buying
these yachts
i was expecting this guy to look like i
don't even know what
and he looks like a panda and then i
googled him and then he looks like a
panda yeah it looks like it looked like
a little fat
happy i don't know i don't know whatever
it's fine at the end of the day he came
he became boys with leonardo dicaprio
all these supermodels all this stuff
whatever but he stole all the money
and he was doing super nefarious stuff
but it turns out that goldman sachs was
participating in it
there's two bankers from goldman sachs
who've been arrested by the u.s
government
uh they've been charged they've had to
turn over you know tens of millions of
dollars
goldman made 600 million dollars in fees
from helping
uh with the fund and so finally goldman
sachs and the malaysian government
reached a settlement today
they are going to pay 3.9 billion
settlement
uh that includes 2.5 billion in cash and
1.4 billion dollars
in assets related to these stuff being
returned
and all of that is uh said to be
much more than goldman had previously
offered but it's still
less than the 4.5 billion dollars that
was taken
and therefore somehow goldman escapes
once again
no criminal charges can i just this is
absurd can i just say something
yeah if it like white collar crime has
always fascinated me because
of the way we treat it in the way we
talk about it versus petty crime
so let's say somebody went and robs a
gas station
what are you gonna say like so the funds
were misappropriated
but we will not be seeking criminal
charges against
of course it's so ridiculous of course
and don't forget
what is the currency of choice the
currency of choice to commit crimes like
this is the us dollar so next time
somebody tells you that
only criminals use bitcoin and show them
what happens in the legacy financial
system all right what's going on with
schools
yeah show them i'm done talking about
joey but if anyone knows where he is
nobody knows
where he is he's reportedly in china if
anyone can find him
and get him i will bring him on the
podcast and i have a lot of questions
for mr joe lo what's going on with
schools
so the cdc so you know how there's this
rhetoric of like open schools don't open
schools it's a whole politicized thing
now the cdc comes out and says
it issued guidelines on education and
child care and it's
come coming down hard in favor of
opening schools
saying children don't suffer much from
coronavirus are less likely
than adults to spread it and they suffer
from being
out of school but then it goes on to say
but hold on if there is substantial
uncontrolled transmission of the virus
you should close them or keep them
closed it's like me
you lost me at cdc does anybody trust
these people anymore
they had one job and one job only
literally
and remember back in february and march
they were telling you masks don't work
so either they they're idiots or they're
liars
it turns out that they end up being
liars because they knew that masks work
and they didn't want to cause an
absolute chaos for people running out
and grabbing ppe
so literally what they did is they went
on national television they lied to the
american people
i don't care what they have to say can
we aside from
cdc can we talk about this education
issue for a second
yesterday yesterday we had a very
interesting conversation about how
maybe covid presents kind of a an
opportunity for
reforming education or kind of
restructuring the way we
learn and maybe virtual education would
allow people to learn from
the best instructors and from the best
schools
instead of being confined to your
teachers at your public school
but at the same time there's kids in
abusive households and things like that
that schools going somewhere during the
day is probably safer for them yeah
imagine being a kid right now and being
stuck at home with your parents and your
parents aren't going to work
like there's kids who are literally
going crazy being like dude get me out
of here
like i gotta go see my i gotta go do
something else so like there's
definitely like
non-education um you know aspects to
this but from a pure education
standpoint
uh most kids would get a better
education
if they were able to get information
from
the internet rather than the schools
they go to and
there's a lot of teachers out there who
are very very talented very very
good at what they do but there's also a
lot of teachers who are not good at what
they do and if you go and you see
what is happening in a lot of american
schools people are appalled right it's
like look we've got to do a better job
educating
our children and so at the end of the
day this isn't going to solve that
problem
either way right like do they go to
school do they not instead what
is going to happen is technologists are
going to reimagine
education you see that with kind of
higher education first so you see things
like lambda school whatever
actually being able to produce um better
trained people my guess is that that
will eventually trickle down into high
school middle school and elementary
school
i still remember the day so when we
moved from bulgaria i started
school in atlanta and then the day that
one day i came home and i was like
like a zombie i was like mom today
in school we watched a movie
like that was like i i didn't even know
that happened in classrooms but it was
great
my favorite thing is that polina told me
when she moved here uh second grade i
think
uh in bulgaria they were solving for x
and like for me that's when like i
checked out of math i was like wait a
minute there's letters in math like i'm
out
but i was failing math but they were
solving for x in second grade in
bulgaria
and she came here and they were doing
addition and she was like wait i'm a
math genius
they were like this kid is a savant all
right what's going on tick tock
tick tock has unveiled a 200 million
dollar fund for its u.s
creators so basically it's gonna
what is it gonna do it's gonna well it's
really hard for people to make money on
tick-tock
right so uh for a whole bunch of
different reasons one they don't share
uh advertising revenue
two is what exactly are you gonna do
from like a direct response standpoint
so it's not like you can create a
tic-tac video and be like hey click on
this link
and uh then go buy this product so it's
all like brand awareness type stuff
or the creators on tick tock who get
famous then try to go and build out
other platforms or do things elsewhere
now take tax like look just keep
creating content and we'll just pay you
money
you know what i've noticed lately a lot
of tick talkers are saying like
let me prank my brother and then they
prank them and then they're like for the
reaction
go check out my instagram so they're
actively trying to funnel people to
their
well they're scared that it's gonna get
banned right in the u.s right and so
tick tock's taking all kinds of steps
here they hired a u.s
uh citizen as the ceo who used to be at
disney uh they have
now created this fund so they're going
to start actually paying creators i'm
sure a lot of that's going to get
funneled to u.s creators
uh they're talking about potentially
hiring an enormous amount of u.s
citizens
um as employees right they're doing
everything they possibly can to prevent
being banned in the united states that
would be a
massive blow to their business uh but at
the end of the day tick-tock's not the
only one who does this a lot of people
don't know this but
uh youtube facebook all of these
platforms pay people for
content uh they usually do it very
quietly
but there are a lot of people getting
paid to create content on platforms
uh they just don't come out and say hey
we have a 200 million dollar fund people
are getting paid on facebook
oh yeah for sure my my grandmother in
bulgaria needs to get paid for creating
content
yeah but i mean look it's not like that
hard to figure out right
i worked at the company so i know a
little bit more but in terms of just the
outward perception you have uh let's say
an uh professional athlete or somebody
who's famous
and they create a show specifically for
facebook do you think that they're doing
that out of the kindness of their heart
no they're figuring out some financial
incentive to get out of it
whether it's facebook directly paying
them or uh they're getting some other
financial incentive of course that's why
they're doing it so
yeah look this makes sense uh the big
question is just like if you're a kid
now all of a sudden do you want to be a
pro athlete or do you want to be a
creator
like being able to be a creator being a
creator is going to become like
the aspirational thing to do and i think
it is really
uh smart of these kids to start building
out their other platforms so they're
just diversified across
with followers instead of just
non-tick-tock absolutely all right
what's up with tesla
tesla takes aim at rivien which is
another electric
uh car company and lawsuit alleging
trade secret theft and poaching of
talent
what do you think i mean i think they
all do that right yeah
they said rivian recruits tesla
employees and encourages them to take
proprietary information as they leave
uh it's pretty hard to prove this stuff
and uh in my opinion um
they're all recruiting from each other
i'm sure tesla is recruiting from rivien
ribbian's recruiting from tesla
somebody's recruiting from nicola
you know somebody's recruiting from the
electric vehicle department of ford or
gm
uh there's only so many people who are
tesla claims that riven has hired 178
former employees
yeah but if you think about that okay so
you've got thousands of employees that
work at tesla
they hired 178 over let's call it the
last five years
still sounds like a big number is it
about 70 of those employees joined the
startup directly from tesla yeah well
okay so
that means 108 of them didn't work at
tesla the time that they were being
recruited
right so two-thirds of them didn't work
there
one-third you know or so did um again
like
at the end of the day there's only so
many people that are skilled uh
to work on these types of problems and
so of course there's going to constantly
be a talent or
and recruit it and this isn't the first
time that tesla has sued a company for
something like this do you think some of
it is
done just to kind of scare people a
little bit
intimidate of course and also to tie up
if all
if you've got billions of dollars and
you can tie somebody up in court you can
get all kinds of things like
it's it's classic you're in a
competition right who's gonna win
tesla's got a very
big lead but i don't see them taking
their foot off the gas at any time so
whatever okay so the next topic
is bezos in a suit so you guys may
remember
we had oh i remember we had a little bet
going
um i forgot what the the bet reward was
but i just remember the bet
i said that jeff bezos if he goes to
this tech hearing
he will wear a suit no you didn't no you
said he would not see look
you see the revisionist history you said
he wouldn't wear a suit and tie
i said he would he would wear like a
t-shirt or
like just just something else other than
a suit and tie
a space out i can't believe she just
tried it tried to change her story
i forgot what i was saying so he um he
said he would wear a suit and tie
well guys we might not know because the
tech ceo hearing will probably be
postponed it was supposed to happen on
monday
uh this coming monday uh the
it's an anti-trust hearing which
basically they're bringing
jeff bezos mark zuckerberg a bunch of
tech ceos in they're basically just
gonna grill them
right and they're gonna say explain to
us why you're not a monopoly
explain to us what anti-trust is yeah
like just explain to us why you're not
anti-competitive explain to us why
you're not a monopoly all these kind of
things
uh amazing messenger well all of these
ceos agreed to come so jeff bezos tim
cook mark zuckerberg sundar pc
right like they all agreed to come and
do this so it's gonna be a big deal
now all of a sudden uh one you've got
covid which kind of put it in limbo
but uh actually it's john lewis is that
is that the guy's name
am i getting that correct uh wait the
john lewis yeah
yeah i thought that was right so john
lewis is the civil rights leader who uh
recently died
he was a elected official um and if i
remember correctly it's because uh the
memorial service for him
is happening uh around the same time or
in the same building
and so they uh they postpone the tech
hearing
there's a lot of uh texts but it's like
they're breathing now well i i think you
think that they're gonna ask mark
zuckerberg about his
uh the sunscreen photo oh my god yes
i mean they asked him about his haircut
so but i just think that
this is buying bezos time to select
which t-shirt he wants to sport
there's zero chance that he's showing i
want him coming in with guns blaze mark
zuckerberg will
a suit you know all right what's going
on taylor swift you know how conor
mcgregor walks into the arena that's how
uh that's how what's his name bezos is
gonna walk in
see are you on drugs right now you look
like you're going to a rave and you're
acting like you're at a rate it's been a
while since i had a laugh attack though
we don't need any of those all right
what's going on with taylor swift taylor
swift
are you pro taylor swift or khan i'm
incredibly pro
taylor swift come at me in the comments
i know you will but i
am i think that she's a fraud i don't
think so
why not she's as much as a fraud as
kanye is a fraud she's not a fraud
no but she she tries to manipulate the
media
to make people feel bad hold on a second
to make people feel bad for her
when when it's okay so take this scooter
box for those that don't know taylor
swift
uh made this big issue with uh scooter
braun
and his partner buying basically the
library of music the rights to her music
but what she doesn't tell people is that
she signed a contract
that the person who was selling the
rights had the legal right to do that
and basically she threw a fit afterwards
being like oh
this is just a man trying to keep a
woman down blah blah whatever
and everyone's just like scooter braun's
like wait what are you talking about
like we literally did a business deal
there's a legal contract you agreed to
this
and i've tried to call you a bunch of
times and you refused to talk to me
about it it's uh he said she said
situation you're not in there you don't
know you haven't seen
it it's a court of law you don't know
there's a court of law if
somebody if you made a bad business deal
that's fine you could say hey i wish i
didn't sell my music think there's more
going on behind the scenes than you know
anyway big taylor swift fan
she didn't sue she didn't sue oh my god
be quiet
okay so during the if she had a leg if
she had a legal case she would have sued
him
just saying all right what's up with
taylor swift i ain't a swifty
nah yes he is when we were in italy we
listened to her whole album and he like
i'll listen to the music that's fine
i'm just saying that i'm not buying the
saab story
okay so taylor swift uh during
the pandemic had a lot of time and
she um released the surprise album at
midnight
today i i will say this we watched the
documentary on taylor swift
there's two things that you can't deny
she's incredibly talented and she works
her ass off
like she she works really really hard in
it you can see she's like literally
writing the songs
on her phone singing them writing more
singing
editing like she works hard and she's
talented
but i still got a bad taste i also think
that
give it time i also think that uh
she's been one of the rare uh artists
that
has been able to reinvent herself time
after time she she became
i was in high school yeah and i always
do feel bad that kanye west interrupted
her on the stage
i'm gonna let you finish but that was
absurd and then beyonce got up and said
what the hell are you
all doing well that's it for today guys
but i have a joke
from a uh lunch money viewer
andre anyone he said
why aren't koala bears considered to be
real bears
uh this is a layup who's who sent us
this one
andre andre it's because they don't have
the qualification
[Music]
oh you read it i read the internet i
read
the internet wasn't that a good one
andre you did a great job will you say
it again for the people
so koala bears aren't considered real
bears no
why aren't because they lack the
qualifications
ha yo andre come on dog come on man
we gotta we gotta step up the joke we
gotta see what are you saying dog koala
come on we gotta step it up man we gotta
step it up i liked it andre these are
bad
jokes all right here's the deal i wanna
know who you guys think is the best
musician of all time rapper singer
whatever you want
put in the comments that's what i want
to know today
who is the best musician of all time i
could be a musician with this shirt
uh no you're going to be fired from the
show with that shirt
breaking dress code looking like a fool
oh i'm gonna get in trouble for that one
by the way yankees want to know gonna go
for the 20th championship
this year we'll see you guys on monday
have a great weekend that's lunch money
well while she's trying to get rich
that's
trying to get her lunch money right pray
for me that i make it to monday
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risks
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends